this was so much fun so thank you this
is the last time we will be seeing each
other I marry good day madam I don't
care if you're marrying for I still love
you you know this guy it was a one-time
thing my husband cheated on me I was
looking for someone to have an affair
with so I could throw it in his face you
screwed your last wife Stensland no no
no okay you've urinated in your shorts
you pointed it good in my face and I
already had to go
Morgan's faithlessness is emboldened me
take a vacation I'm moving in here for a
while what you said it looked like a
pirate ship and smelled of beef noodles
and you said it smelled of man and you
were right Grady what are you doing here
I live here now a woman we bonded over
the mutual hatred of you Morgan I don't
hate you per se shut up all right please
please stop talking right now okay so oh
this is so twisted we got to get out
there we got to get some I get a cash in
a bank some strange car no yes no drink
it 92% alcohol right yep that was a
delightful bubble boss
adventures are Upton all around you I'm
hating it a staple for one guy who's
pissed off that his one-night stand
isn't just a one-night stand I can't
wait to get these people out of my life
oh god you're weird
[Music]
my pond
you're screwed
[Applause]
[Music]
marriage
[Music]
you use a brain-damaged ape they all on
[ __ ]
[Music]
you